hallo mein name ist supernett sich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video von dir ja genau ich befinde mich
gerade mal wieder bei meinen eltern hier
zu hause
jeder kennt es einerseits an dem
hintergrund und andererseits in der
komplett beschissenen video beleuchtung
denn das übernimmt gerade die
google-startseite die hier auf meinem
laptop geöffnet ist aber meine damen und
herren hier sieht es natürlich alles
schon im titel eingeblendet das ist der
grund warum wir auf dieses video
draufgelegt habe ich werde euch heute
zeigen was ich auf meinem iphone
befindet das ist übrigens sehr schöner
pops orchester von de vega das superding
kann man das handy einfach mit
festhalten das ist handy hinstellen das
seht ihr jetzt gerade nicht aber steht
wo fangen wir dann an meine damen und
herren also hier auf der rechten seite
habe ich ein paar apps und hier auf der
startseite habe ich würde sagen wir
fangen erst mal mit der ersten app die
ich nämlich oben links haben und zwar
nachrichten ja nutze ich nie und dann
eigentlich nur whatsapp rechts neben
nachrichten haben wir dann auch den
kalender wie teilt die stinknormale
kalender app habe ich halt meine termine
drin dann habe ich hier oben noch fotos
kamera auf solche apps muss ich glaube
ich jetzt nicht wirklich eingehen mit
der kamera macht fotos und die sind dann
in der fotos youtube ich weiß nicht ob
ich die app schon kennt ist jetzt ganz
neu auf dem markt kann man videos
hochladen
der glaube ich noch nie von gehört sleep
cycle das ist eine app die dokumentiert
wie ich schlafe also man stellt sich
abends nicht normal ein bäcker der dann
irgendwie klingelt sondern die app weckt
einen ganz ganz langsam auf und schaut
dann mit dem tiefschlaf ist und wann du
im mittleren und im wann man vielleicht
auf toilette putzen war oder so man kann
halt hier so einstellen ich will jetzt
irgendwie um 8.45 aufwachen und
keine ahnung wann und dann kann man auch
die statistik der letzten mal angucken
und dann steht die zum beispiel habe ich
super von 228 bis 745 geschlafen das ist
super luca 5 stunden 16 schlaf damit
kommt es auf jeden fall über die runden
whatsapp sind wir hier im krieg oder war
es trotzdem kennt glaube ich auch jeder
mittlerweile ist dieser stinknormale
messenger messenger der stinknormale
messenger von facebook also ich verstehe
ehrlich gesagt nicht wie die auf die
idee gekommen sind es nicht mehr
integriert in facebooks machen sondern
da in der extrem dass man die das macht
null sinn warten hier vorne das auch
gedanken stinken ich kann karten löschen
die gast deren scheiß ernst oder was zu
wollen lokalvideo auf während dessen
jets und bombe auf seine haushalte ganz
normaler apple and genauso wie male wo
ich meine ganzen mails und habe facebook
ist jetzt kennt ihr glaube ich auch alle
acht übrigens dass es überhaupt keine
werbung für irgendeine app die ich euch
hier zeige wetteronline das einfach eine
app die meiner meinung nach besser das
wetter bestimmen kann als die apple
wetter-app weil das apple wetter
das wird irgendwie aus los angeles
gemessen und es stimmt irgendwie nie uhr
ich würde mal sagen diese app zeigt mir
die uhr an gleis oder notizen diese app
nutze ich mit am häufigsten neben
instagram snapshot und whatsapp auf
meinem handy weil ich da einfach alles
drin stehen habe also sei es eine
einkaufsliste wenn ich mal irgendwo muss
es irgendwelche sachen die ich noch zu
tun haben im haushalt auf jeden fall
schreiben wir alles rein also auch wenn
ich irgendwo sehr ok der fußball lust
ich oder hier irgendwie das zitat finde
ich ganz cool notizen app ist bei mir
voll gefüllt mit müll soundcloud und
spotify das sind die apps mit denen ich
eigentlich primär meine musik höre übers
handy also es gibt ja leute die machen
das über youtube und laden sich das dann
irgendwie bei solche drittanbieter apps
herunter die wieder- oder so ich mache
das eigentlich nur dass soundcloud und
diesen premium service dass man das
quasi offline hören kann und oder
spotify übrigens habe ich auch eine
menge spotify playlisten also so hip hop
oder deutsch web oder elektro oder so
auch schon mit vielen followern also
erst mal nachgedacht wen findet ihr auch
in der beschreibung immer verlinkt also
wenn ihr wissen wollen was ich für musik
hören könnt ihr einfach da folgen ich
krieg da kein geld für und so aber keine
ahnung mich fragen wird sie
einstellungen warum habe ich eigentlich
dumm apps wie einstellungen oder uhr auf
meiner frontpage blitzer de pro damit
man sieht blitz einschlägt app store das
halt so einem türkischen basar wo man
sich apps ersteigern kann da sagt apple
ja auch bezahlt 40 cent du sagst mir ich
hab nur 30 ja sagen ja okay dann gib uns
so läuft das david nutt sich derzeit
nicht mehr so viel wie früher also
früher habe ich wirklich ihr rund um die
uhr bilder habe gesagt ja auch ich
mitgemacht habe ich gegessen jetzt kommt
sich dann wieder aus weißem irgendwie
scheiße geht derzeit kritisch nur noch
irgendwie was wenn ich irgendwie müde
bilden und so wie beim handy hänger oder
wenn ich irgendwie war grade dann weiter
nicht also ich kann mir bei twitter
folgen da sage ich immer wenn ich luca
reagierte aber eigentlich bringt bringt
keinen mehrwert folgt mir lieber bei
instagram instagram bekommst du kein
geld nein geld ist eine app die hat
genau neun witze ja und ich mag das
social playstation blade ist einfach ein
soziales schwert also das ist quasi ein
schwert was genau sozial schneidet also
nicht jetzt irgendwie wenn du dein brot
hast und dann hat sie schneidet dahin
hat durch und dann hat der einigen die
mehr oder weniger alle social werde das
ist schwer das ist zeigt youtube
statistiken aber ich glaube ich für euch
nicht so interessant youtube studio sind
auch youtube statistiken
also da kann ich sehen
das video kann man scheiße an davon soll
nicht definitiv mehr hochladen tabellen
das ist eine app die ich wirklich lieben
youtuber nur empfehlen kann uns war es
das einfach
dieses google tabellen keine ahnung was
dingsda und das ist ja ganz geil weil da
kann man dann einerseits mit seinem
laptop wenn man zu hause so dass sein pc
oder keine ahnung was darauf zugreifen
und hat auch mit seinem handy also wenn
man ablaufplan hat oder ideen oder keine
ahnung wie ideen oder so hat man die
immer synchronisiert dabei also so wie
meine notizen hält auch also eigentlich
brauchte jedoch nicht telefon
damit bereite ich mir mein mittagessen
zu snap chat super ist der karton auf
dem eine kamera gerade steht das ist ein
karton von snapshot denen die mir zu
weihnachten geschickt haben snapshot ist
eine app die ihr glaube ich auch kennt
also man kann sich selbst verschicken
bilder schicken et cetera safari das ist
eine app über die man sich relativ
leicht in afrika safaris buchen kann
also die haben dann sonderangebote und
so war es alles die nächste app
instagram hier unten rechts ich habe
instagram instagram partys im gestrigen
video noch nicht richtig mitbekommen
haben sollte
ich habe einen neuen kanal außerdem auf
youtube aufgemacht und zwar werde ich
auf diesem kanal meine instagram stories
wöchentlich hochladen
der kanal ist in der beschreibung
verlinkt also lasst ja gerne mal ein abo
da und da könnt ihr dann wöchentlich
immer sehen quasi so ein wöchentlicher
blog was ich gemacht habe in der woche
und wenn ich live stream zwar mache dann
wenn die da auch hochladen also hey lass
abonniert ja das ist auf jeden fall die
erste seite meiner apps und das hier ist
die zweite seite also da habe ich jetzt
auch noch ein paar ordner ich will jetzt
nicht jede einzelne karte dadurch gehen
erstmalig in fotografie ordner im
display memories oben links damit mach
ich quasi warum habe ich diese chance
hat eigentlich das kann ich einmal
löschen lowepro habe ich noch ich doch
das erklärt sich von selbst camera
connector kann ich das gleiche dilemma
bleibt warum die kamera mit mandy zu
verbinden facebook nutzen eigentlich
diese ganzen insel models um sich ein
pickel weg zu machen ich nutze es
eigentlich viel mehr um beispielsweise
max ab und zu mal ein drittes auge auf
die stirn zu setzen
prisma war was ist prisma das habe ich
gerade gelöscht wo sich ja immer dass
ich das irgendwie auf ihr handy oder was
das überhaupt ist
kanada kann man sich so in mode sind die
augen setzen das eigentlich ganz lustig
wie es die oder mit bearbeite ich meine
instagram bilder und producer das ist so
einem ihm da kann man so - mitmachen
dann habe ich hier den apple worten oder
werde ich jetzt allerdings nicht darauf
eingehen da sind diese ganzen standard
apple apps drin die ich einfach die
brauche wie beispielsweise airport oder
halt wetter oder am rechner ich meine
wer muss rechnen ich habe so ein fettes
gehirn fragt mich irgendwas ich kann es
euch beantworten luca weises 29 43
und sonst dass ich nicht 40 ja das ist
ich weiß nicht so weit entfernt dann
habe ich ihn spiele ordner habe ich
darin kennen die crash kennen glaube ich
jeder minecraft vielleicht kennt ihr das
so ein würfelspiel cottbus das ist ein
trinkspiel genauso wie piccolo die
muschel das ist von spongebob diese muss
oder kann man so sachen aufsagen pokémon
go aber seit wochen monaten jahren nicht
gespielt war iran habe ich mir nur
runter geladen weil das bei apple so
krass angepriesen wurde war allerdings
größte kacke die sga ich hasse es für
die man einfach standardmäßig internet
brauchen wie zu spielen was mache ich
denn nicht mal im flieger sitzen weil
ich das einfach nicht spielen deswegen
habe ich auch noch kann die frösche weil
das zumindest einzige was man spielen
kann offen ist so krass im internet
immer zu sein zu müssen
einige routen in jamie tomo übersetzer
face app pocket cam kompendien von fifa
und der generator vermins und sie jetzt
fragt ihr euch bestimmt luca warum ist
eine google übersetzer etwa deinen
spielen also wenn man da beleidigungen
eingibt und die von der stimme von
google bei selbst vorlesen lässt dann
ist es schon hart lustig da habe ich
hier vorne noch eine travel app das sind
einfach so sachen drin wie herr berlin
die brauche ich eigentlich auch nicht
mehr hat miles and more wo ich halt
flugmeilen mit sammeln um dann eine
basecap für den bruder von mir die euch
kaputt gemacht oder kann ich das auch
mal löschen deutsche bahn apps
staumelder airbnb oberrhein also sachen
wenn man irgendwo unterwegs ist dann
habe ich hier noch sonstige ist da sind
halt die alle sachen drin die man keine
richtigen kategorie zuordnen kann zum
beispiel gegen so ein qr code scanner
immobilie in amazon essenslieferanten
sportnews lieferheld paypal sohnes
gottes keine ziegel sondern das ist eine
ganz gute plattform wenn man sich
sneaker oder klamotten kaufen will dann
habe ich halt hier noch den sozialen
ordner da muss man sich wirklich gut
benehmen wenn man da reingehen
möchte das wirklich relativ soziales
ambiente vorhanden dass unsere sachen
drin wie beispielsweise jodel oder
netflix oder halt so was wie hootsuite
oder keine ahnung fans ist ihre freunde
ich bin halt immer fans unterwegs
deswegen brauche ich solche apps halt
und dann habe ich hier vorne noch clash
of clare und weise letzter zeit einfach
sehr viel spiele und great einfach auch
wegen klamotten schauen und so das waren
dann allerdings eigentlich schon alle
meine apps aber ich habe jetzt alle
erklärt die ich auf der frontpage habe
ich wirklich die ganze zeit nutzen und
die hier vorne und so die ich halt eher
weniger häufig nutzt habe ich jetzt
nicht so viel erklärt also ich weiß ich
wenn es euch jetzt mega interessiert
luca was machst du mit watch krank dann
schreiten wir gerne in die kommentare so
welcher app wir noch ein paar mehr
informationen möchte dann kann ich euch
ja vielleicht auf den kommentaren
verantworten als wenn jetzt einer
schreibgeräte was ist denn davon dass
wir neben das tor dann irgendwie 1000
likes oder sondern werde ich dann
natürlich dann bin ich darauf antworten
sonst würde ich an der jetzt auch das
video hier beenden meine damen und
herren wie bereits gesagt und in der
beschreibung findet ihr einige spotify
playlisten von mir eingeblendet habe ich
jetzt mal komplette mucke reingepackt
was ich derzeit höhere in richtung hip
hop deutschpop oder auch aus ibm habe
ich am meisten und ihr findet in der
beschreibung unter anderem einen
instagram eingeblendet wurde mir gern
folgen damit zwei millionen follower auf
eine danke dafür
da hab ich gestern einen kindheit bild
von mir hochgeladen und ihr findet noch
einen neuen kanal in der beschreibung
eingeblendet wo wünschen sich jetzt
meine story hochkommt und ja das war es
vom video-team sie das was jetzt hier
vom video das war's jetzt ihr vom video
hier können jetzt jemanden kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken ihr findet ihr zwei andere
videos und managen abonnent seid könnt
ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]